oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande interview plus de 3 millions de
mineurs sont prostituées dans le monde
dont plusieurs milliers d'enfants en
france un fléau contre lequel se bat
notre invité armel le big mac os bonjour
merci d'être avec nous dans ce nouveau
numéro de la grande interview vous êtes
présidente de la cpe agir contre la
prostitution des enfants depuis
1986 à votre association lutte contre
les exploitations sexuel qui implique à
des mineurs en france et à l'étranger
vous êtes à la tête de cette association
depuis une dizaine d'années vous avez
décidé de réorienter
la thématique de votre association sur
la situation en france précisément on va
se focaliser donc sur cette situation
dans l'hexagone quel est l'âge moyen de
ces mineurs
concernés par la prostitution et de quel
type de prostitution est ce qu'on parle
alors très bonne question parce que la
joie lia change et puis il y aura changé
depuis les dix ans où j'avais décidé de
prendre ce problème mon chat la réponse
est clairement ça se rajeunit de plus en
plus alors maintenant l'âge moyen alors
on va dire c'est 14 15 ans sachant qu'il
ya maintenant des petites filles et je
dis bien des petites filles et non pas
des jeunes femmes qui a 12 ans rentre
dans la prostitution mais c'est vrai que
l'âge moyen c'est celui-là est en effet
le point qui me concerne et nous
concerne tous c'est que ça ne touche pas
seulement les gamines du proxénétisme
des cités c'est un sujet qui aujourd'hui
peut effectivement tombé j'ai envie de
dire sur n'importe quel gamine est
injustement quel est le profil un peu
cheap de c2c à dole et alors ça touche
tous les milieux sociaux alors je dirais
effectivement ça touche tous les milieux
sociaux dans la mesure où le point de
départ c'est quand même toujours une
fragilité 1 c'est quand on rentre là
dedans quand les gamines rentrer là
dedans il ya toujours un point
d'achoppement qui peut être très lourd
c'est à dire des elles ont vécu un
traumatisme enfants qu'ils aient pu être
d'ordre sexuel ou autre ça peut être
aussi des problèmes de mésestime de soi
à travers le harcèlement scolaire ça
peut être aussi les problèmes familiaux
qui font que ces gamines qui assez
souvent sont de bonnes petites élèves
donc on ne voit rien arriver bascule
tout d'un coup et les signaux en fait
c'est ce que je passe mon temps à lire
pour alerter les signaux ils sont quand
même à peu près toujours les mêmes ça
commence par une part eu des chutes des
notes à l'école des fugues des fugues à
répétition et après salle par tad dents
et on expliquera peut-être le fait de
même tout à l'heure parce que c'est
vraiment quasiment toujours la même
chose et le même process elle s'entraîne
entre elles et puis elle tombe là dedans
dans un premier temps parce qu'elles ont
l'impression que elle se met en valeur
qu'ils mettent leur corps en valeur et
puis assez vite elles sont sont repérés
soit sur le dette soit tout simplement
par la bande par des petits proxénètes
qui ont très bien compris que c'était
une façon formidable de se faire du fric
sans grand risque puisque l'on trouve en
risque que ça passe encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup soul herrada et surtout sans
gros investissement comme il y en a dans
la drogue vous dites qu'au départ il ya
une fragilité cela concerne les
adolescentes de tout milieu social mais
alors comment est-ce qu'on en arrive
comment est-ce que ces adolescentes en
arrive à un moment
décider de marche ont marchandé leur
corps
alors ça démarre presque jamais comme ça
on a beau dire c'est là près du du fric
eux n'ont cessé effective des gamines
qui pour des raisons x ou y où on vit de
d'avoir la liberté de faire ce qu'elles
ont envie de faire louis l'argent est
une composante qui est mais c'est
surtout des gamines qui entraîné par
d'autres affaire rarissime qu'une gamine
que part tout seul comme ça ça existe à
s'agripper c'est rarissime en général
c'est une copine qui pour une raison ou
une autre a été en contact avec sa fille
émilie regard tu tues avoir maquillé on
va se mettre sur eux sur le net et puis
et puis voilà les prédateurs arrive
assez vite aussi elle même très très
très très rapidement sans vérification
d'âge ou de quoi que ce soit donc voilà
donc au départ c'est quand même un peu
la fête et c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
c'est si difficile ce phénomène c'est
qu' il n'y a aucun doute que au départ
sont consentantes quand elle vivons ne
sont pas forcés pour ça et c'est après
que la pression arrivé qu'on découvre
des situations tout à fait dramatique de
gamine qui peuvent être séquestrés qui
sont dans des armées ennemies qui sont
obligés de travailler beaucoup et qui
voit pas beaucoup
mille odeurs ni le nid les billets
eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire qu'elles ont
quasiment plus rien et vous dites que le
phénomène touche aussi de plus en plus
de d'adolescentes issus de milieux
privilégiés c'est quelque chose que vous
avez constaté aussi ces dernières années
à partir du moment où on considère
québec qui m'est fait liée aussi aux
fragilités de l'adolescence je vais dire
sauf qu'aujourd'hui il ya cette espèce
de deux nouveaux pour trop fier l'on va
dire de de mise en valeur de soi etc qui
fait que oui bien sûr alors je veux pas
faire peur aux parents et ça ne tombe
pas sur n'importe qui je dis juste qu'il
faut être extrêmement vigilant c'est
pour ça que j'ai tout il parlait des
signaux les avoir en tête c'est pas que
du décrochage scolaire parce qu'à
l'adolescence doullens coup il faut
vraiment se poser des questions quand
les gamines pas là sont accrochés à leur
téléphone en fait il ya plein plein
plein de simyo qu'on essaye
effectivement 2 2 voilà on essaye de
faire passer aux parents et oui aux
travailleurs sociaux à tous ceux qui
entourent les enfants le fait que ce
qu'il faut qu'il soit très très vigilant
parce que je le répète légal ils sont
entassés coquine et au début elles sont
tout ce qu'il faut pour dire des quoi je
veux faire ce que je veux de mon corps
et c'est donc il faut effectivement
essayé de leur faire passer l'idée
qu'une fois qu'on a mis dans gran
injectant malheureusement c'est très
très difficile d'en sortir et justement
quand les synodes alertes sont détectés
par les parents est ce qu'ils ont encore
le temps d'agir où les jeunes filles
sont déjà entraînés dans un phénomène
qui peut être les dépassent complètement
alors les les parents non on en reçoit
de plus en plus et je veux dire que vous
est-il qui est vraiment c'est
pratiquement la fait pas une seul
endroit où où effectivement on reçoit
beaucoup de parents parce que le
phénomène des petites filles à d'autres
associations qui commence à s'en occuper
mais les parents c'est vrai que c'est
assez c'est assez surréaliste qui leur
arrive quand même parce que c'est vrai
que a si souvent ils repèrent ces fameux
studio et il essaye d'aller alerté la
police
ibm des mouchards sur les téléphones de
leurs de leurs enfants donc si ils sont
même souvent capable de dire que leur
fille et appelle en droit et qu'il
faudrait aller la chercher le problème
c'est le manque de moyens évidemment de
la police qui en général
à temps de mettre le doigt sur un vrai
réseau tant qu'ils sont pas sûrs d'avoir
aller chercher toutes les gamines et moi
je ne sais puisque le patron de la
brigade de protection des mineurs ça
fait des années que je me courait après
disons que commissaire c'est pas
possible que vous laissiez là il faisait
mairie nous on n'a pas mis les moyens
mis la formation pour savoir dans quel
état sont ces gamines donc on attend
nous on est on est formé pour pour
courser les réseaux alors c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup plus facile les réseaux
des piges eriane bonne enseigne sera là
on sait comment ça marche ils savent
comment ça ces gamines sait pas qui est
un phénomène assez nouveau et je dois
dire que les policiers comme les
magistrats comme beaucoup de
professionnels de justice de police ne
connaissait pas le phénomène donc je
n'aurai beaucoup jeter la pierre au
débat dix ans c'est pas possible il faut
vous ouvriez les yeux il ya des milliers
de petites filles c'est quand même moi
qui ai lancé le 5 à 8 mille enfants à
l'époque tenant me traiter de folle
aujourd'hui on parle de 15000 et encore
parce que le plan vient de sortir et qui
peut justifier qu'ils aient un plan mais
mais vraiment oui c'est sûr que les
professionnels n'étaient pas formés en
plus touché un sujet c'est la sexualité
quand même c'est difficile de la borda
et beaucoup donc on fait beaucoup de
formation de professionnels maintenant
on reviendra justement sur le plan que
vous évoquez l instant le plan
gouvernemental pour lutter contre ce
fléau on parle beaucoup d'adolescentes
est ce que les jeunes garçons sont aussi
concernés par ce sujet de la
prostitution alors ça va être le
prochain sujet de la cp figurez-vous
donc la question est très bien briefé
parce que c'est vrai qu'on parle
toujours des filles et on sait qu'il y a
qu il ya maintenant des garçons qui
s'adonnent aussi se satisfaire de la
prostitution enfantine c'est alors la
déjà que l'équipe passé sous les radars
alors maintenant les garçons passent
doublement sous les radars parce qu on
combine la prostitution est quand même
assez souvent l'homosexualité du coucher
entre guillemets double peine et là
franchement c'est pas encore un sujet
qui a émergé mais oui bien sûr il ya les
gars vous dirais que ce phénomène s'est
considérablement aggravée depuis
internet et les réseaux sociaux vous
vous évoquiez ces jeunes adolescentes
qui passent un temps infini sur leur
portable cela ne veut pas dire que tout
pendant
dans ce fléau mais quand même il ya
quelque chose le fait peut-être que les
parents sont plus tenus à l'écart aussi
de l'intimité qu'elle crée avec un monde
qui est inconnu de leurs familles de
leurs proches oui alors c'est pour ça
que je vous disais que là on parle de
15000 euros forme et rachid ça fait des
années que je réclame une vraie étude
sur le sujet mais voilà là aussi il faut
des moyens une sensibilisation et je
fais juste une petite parenthèse parce
que je suis pas sûr d'avoir le temps de
le placer je remercie les médias je
n'aurais pas eu les médias avec moi je
vous jure je crois que je serai encore
trois ans en arrière à dire écoutez
ouvrez les yeux ça se passe sous vos
yeux et en particulier augmentation du
phénomène du fait des réseaux sociaux il
n'ya aucun doute à tuer a donc je le
répète ça deloitte est beaucoup plus
vaste que ce qu'on imagine aujourd'hui
et c'est pas du tout je mens je mens
glorifie je pense qu'il faut vraiment
aller regarder de près ce phénomène qui
se développe où ils sont considérables
grâce aux réseaux sociaux qui est le
quai de la zone par définition des
jeunes des jeunes entre eux parce que ce
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que les
petits proxénète moi je considère que
des victimes aussi procédé qui sont à
peine plus âgés que leurs que leurs
victimes dont qui sont plus dans le
monde il est aux problèmes sont
consentantes
on les protège on est là pour leur
fournir les préservatifs la nourriture
passé comme un espèce de monde de
bisounours qui est dans la réalité
quelque chose d'effroyable quand on met
le doigt on va revenir sur
l'organisation justement de de ce
phénomène mais je voudrais aussi vous
voir votre ressenti sur ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre la crise
sanitaire et puis ces nombreux
confinement est ce que ça a eu un impact
aussi sur sur le phénomène est ce que
vous avez senti ces derniers mois une
accélération
dramatique pour vous dire ce que je peux
sentir une accélération il faudrait que
je pisse chiffrés et avoir un état des
lieux du phénomène je pense oui enfin
bon c'est que le
l'aco ville a certainement favorisé
ce qui se passait intra muros et on
pouvait pas y avoir véritablement accès
mais j'ai envie de dire que c'est la
même façon ça a porté sur la santé
mentale des ados en face et c'est ça
c'est sûrement pas améliorée maintenant
dans quelles proportions ça a contribué
à l'aggraver je suis absolument
incapable de vous répondre mais alors
pourquoi est-ce que internet les réseaux
sociaux dans le sentiment de faciliter
ce passage à la prostitution
au bon alors là j'ai pas je suis pas
besoin de beaucoup de temps pour vous
les expliquer
elle se met en scène dans des dents des
détenus on va dire affriolantes elle
poste une ou deux photos elles l ont
immédiatement et pour avoir fait l'essai
au bureau des quantités de fois quand
j'avais 10 qui viennent on rentre
évidemment dont les seuils de dire voilà
je suis jeune et arrive son temps etc en
l'espace de dix minutes on a 60 clients
qui ce qui se présente donc après il ya
effectivement la problématique de ou
faire ça et donc c'est il faut passer
par ces petits et qui proxénètes qui
arrive à louer des chambres d'hôtel des
arbitres nba mais c'est vraiment très
très très simple de mettre en route un
un système prostitutionnel de ces de ces
gamines on en reparle dans un instant on
voit une toute petite pause et on se
retrouve juste après à mal le big mac os
[Musique]
vous êtes de retour dans la grande
interview nous sommes en compagnie
d'armel le big mac os présidente de
l'association ac peut agir contre la
prostitution des enfants armel le big
mac os qui sont les responsables de
cette prostitution derrière les écrans
téléphone d'ordinateurs des jeunes
adolescents puisque ce sont elles qui
sont principalement concernées par par
ce fléau qui organise très concrètement
les rencontres avec les clients est ce
que ce sont des réseaux très organisés
ou alors ce sont plutôt le fait de
l'individu seul aussi isolé peut-être
dans leur chambre d'ado alors déjà et du
vraiment qui sont les responsables
malheureusement il y en a pas assez on
le savait vous rapporte les parents les
logiciens alors j'ai un grand
responsable s'il faut pointer du doigt
quelque chose c'est quand même ce ce
phénomène de société ces petites lolitas
dont on parlait il ya dix quinze ans les
le fait de se battre on se mettre en
valeur toute la communication sur la
femme peut la femme objet et puis et
puis quand même l'accès aux eaux porno
on peut pas ne pas en parler y qu'il
veut du j'ai presque envie de dire un
fléau quand même sur
l'actualisation des réseaux sociaux et
l'accès l'accès au porno qui
dématérialise complètement lax l'acte
sexuel c'est à dire que quand les
gamines parle de ça c'est voilà c'est un
acte sexuel
complètement dénué d'affect donc la
relation à l'autre
et alors c'est pas grave au début
vraiment l dissocie complètement le fait
d'être amoureuse à ou le fait de ceux
s'adonner à la prostitution si les
rentrées guillemets devant de son corps
donc c'est aussi ce toutes ses
composantes sociétal qui font que voilà
elles n'ont pas de mode d'emploi et ça
leur paraît pas du tout
incongru que de gagner de l'argent
puisque quand elles partent là dedans
c'est quand même gagné l'argent au delà
du fait de se mettre en valeur mais
gagner aussi de l'argent l'argent de la
liberté on va dire et d'accès aux
produits les vêtements le truc au début
oui bien sûr que ça et donc c'est tout
ce phénomène là qu'il faut bien sûr
incriminé donc c'est ça qui est
compliqué quand on veut se contre contre
ce fléau et puis après en effet ces
réseaux sociaux qui facilite
considérablement le lien entre les uns
et les autres mais c'est bien pour ça
que les professionnels disent nous on
est complètement démuni devant ce test
de fléaux qui arrive alors qu'ils
arrivent aussi beaucoup quand je vous
disais ça touche tout le monde
clairement ça touche aussi beaucoup les
gamines qui sont dans les foyer de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance c'est une des
raisons on reviendra certainement sur la
grille attaquer tout à l'heure une des
raisons qui fait que le ministre s'est
intéressé au sujet parce que là
franchement personne ne peut nier le
fait que les gamines se recrutent entre
elles et que tous les petits proxénète
tourne autour des 1 pour faire fugue et
les filles et les choper très facilement
ces adolescents n'ont pas le sentiment
de subir la situation est ce qu'elle se
revendique est ce qu'elle revendique
finalement ces passages à l'acte ce qui
devient une activité elles ont sentiment
d'être victimes ou pas du tout pas du
tout au début on parle bien du début
parce qu'après une fois qu'elles sont
enfermés là dedans et je vous dis dans
des conditions qui souvent puisque la cp
est partie civile dans 40 procès on voit
bien ce qui se passe quand réellement le
sujet arrive c'est dramatique mais au
début c'est vraiment essayé c'est là
qu'est la difficulté des travailleurs
sociaux comme comment les accrocher
quand elle dit mais foutez moi la paix
parce que ce que je veux je fais ce que
je veux mon corps est alors il est où le
problème
voilà donc en effet au départ elles sont
réellement consentante et jean répète
c'est pour ça que de protection des
mineurs ou les policiers qui reçoivent
les parents diva soul et qu'on fasse
abordés prenez une carte d'abonnement à
l'affût bière en fût bras
voilà et en effet ce qui se passe et ça
c'est un vrai problème et c'est pour ça
que là c'est plus mobile sur tout ce
qu'on peut appeler sensibilisation
prévention est passé qu'une fois
qu'elles soient rentrés dedans c'était
extrêmement difficile de les en faire
sortir parce que c'est une addiction
comme une autre quand on est passés par
ces ses sensations et voir
éventuellement effroyable la plupart
sont drogués comme un porc pour subir
tous ses assauts physique
mais ces espèces d'adrénaline qui fait
que quand on les sort de là et on a fait
des films là-dessus redessiné avec des
vrais amis il y avait des gus à eybens
la vie quotidienne leur paraît tellement
quelconque pour intéressante est là qu
elle tire parti se pose aussi quand même
la question du profil des clients parce
qu'avoir des relations sexuelles avec
une adolescente de 12 ans ça s'appelle
de la pédo pornographie pédophile et
dauphine s'appelle de la pédophilie est
effectivement là aussi gros problème
pour pour envoyer mes choper les clients
et clients disent tous mais attendez moi
je n'ai pas du tout compris qu'elle
était qu'elle était mineure parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle se met quand même en
valeur de telle sorte que ils peuvent
prétendre ne pas imaginer qu'elle soit
mineure ils savent pertinemment qu'elles
le sont mais alors comment démontré
qu'ils savaient pas ce qu'elles montrent
bien sûr qu'ils mentent sur leur âge
donc donc du coup les clients on
n'arrive pas beaucoup elle est à
l'échoppé et je crois que le derniers
chiffres dont j'ai entendu parler c'est
que je crois qu'il ya eu mille mille et
quelques clients qui ont été pris entre
il met la main dans le sac et pour un
nombre de passes absolument considérable
comme vous l'imaginez si je prends le
nombre de gars me multiplié par le
nombre de passes quelques verres par
jour donc donc voila quand je lui dire
fais les clients effectuant assez sûr
que nous notre rêve ces coraux c'est
qu'on fasse disparaître les clients
qu'on fasse aussi de sensibilisation
auprès des filles bien sûr mais des
garçons aussi en expliquant ce que c'est
que d'obliger du corps d'une femme qui
n'est pas profondément consentante alors
là si c'était un éternel problème du
consentement on l'a on peut évoquer est
la police et la justice vous semble
aujourd'hui être mobilisés sur sur ce
sujet qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent dans ce
contexte un peu délicat vous l'avez dit
où l'adolescente ne se sent pas
forcément victime le client peut se
défendre
on met en avant finalement
cet âge qu'il ignorait si bagdad au lac
de cette jeune prostituée
aujourd'hui un changement alors
aujourd'hui un peu plus alertes sur ces
domaines j'étais juré il faut dire que
les choses ont profondément changé
c'est pas le cas mais en tout cas oui je
suis convaincu qu'il y a enfin une prise
de conscience
alors pas du tout au même niveau selon
les interlocuteurs qu'on peut avoir mais
en tout cas une prise de conscience
qu'il se passe quelque chose de d'un peu
grave parce que parce que dès qu'on
évoque les réseaux sociaux on s'aperçoit
que ça peut exploser mais un an de façon
exponentielle et que au fond là tout le
monde s'est dit on peut plus fermer les
yeux sur ce phénomène qui a été quand
même tabou et je suis un bon témoin pour
vous le dire un tabou pendant des années
où on ne voulait pas moi dix ans et non
non mais tout ça c'est quelques gamines
je le répète c'est tourner appelé passe
à proximité des cités on appelait ça des
tournants dans les cités c'était juste
ça nous concerne et pas c'était
malheureusement quelques gamines qui
était en cause aujourd'hui on parle d'un
vrai phénomène et c'est pour ça que les
politiques ont commencé à filtrer et
justement le gouvernement a donc
présenté en novembre dernier un plan
interministériel de 14 millions d'euros
pour lutter contre la prostitution des
mineurs et en particulier des
adolescentes parmi les principales
actions annoncées par nom figure des
actions de prévention sur les réseaux
sociaux aussi dans les écoles et puis
aussi une meilleure formation des
personnels en contact avec les jeunes
est ce qu'il vous satisfait ce plan
alors je vais répondre à deux niveaux la
première chose qu'ils aient obligé de
rendre graff vraiment haderer attaque et
qui qui bat reçu je crois une semaine
après avoir pris ses fonctions dire je
vais un peu insisté quand même mais bon
voilà le rendez vous a été pris et et il
était non pas encore au courant de ce
qui pouvait se passer en tout cas
sensibiliser parce que quand même les
foyers les sociale à l'enfance ils
savaient ils avaient entendu parler de
ce que je vous évoquez à savoir que là
il y avait des recrutements qui
commençait à faire de façon un peu
massive et à l'époque il m'avait dit
armel je vous promets qu'on va s'atteler
au problème ha bon le confinement est
arrivé là dessus
comme un lâche que j'ai aussi le regard
sur les politiques je me suis dit bon
c'est des promesses qui ne seront pas
duré bien je dois quand même rendre
grâce à adrien taquet d'avoir monté
cette commission avec cette procureur
jean reno qui a fait un boulot
remarquable un nombre d'auditions
incroyable c'est beaucoup beaucoup
participé et a sorti un plan qui par
définition est insatisfaisant mais qui a
le mérite d'exister et est aussi vous
l'avez évoqué et c'est pour moi c'est
très important il a réussi à mobiliser
d'autres ministres que jusqu'à
maintenant alors bon les cités d'art
banin dupond-moretti possible sur les
villes il était là le jour de la
présentation du plan ils ont
effectivement non seulement fait acte de
présence mais réellement pris donner le
sentiment de prendre en compte ce
phénomène donc pour moi c'est une c'est
une belle avancée problème c'est voilà
qu'est ce qui va se passer derrière
alors les 14 millions
que vous dire par rapport à 0 c'est
énorme les 14 millions pour régler le
problème quand on sait tout ce boulot il
faut mettre en place de formations des
professionnels de prévention la
prévention dans les jt
oui puisque je vous disais que la
prévention c'est prioritaire parce
qu'une fois qu'elles tombent dedans je
vous assure que c'est la croix et la
bannière pour les récupérer et ça coûte
cher à l'état parce que c'est des
gamines qui sont fracassés est vraiment
frais cas c'est donc évidemment que le
bon sens consiste à lire intervenant
avant mais comme comme pour beaucoup de
choses intervenant avant pour éviter
qu'elle bascule et donc intervenir avant
ça veut dire déjà respecter les fameuses
trois séances un d'éducation affective
et sexuelle à l'école qui ne sont pas
pratiquées tout le monde le sait mais
pourquoi ils sont pas pratiqués parce
que les enseignants sont pas formés à
aborder ce genre de sujet qui te le
répète un sexualité très difficile à
aborder devant une collectivité de
trente gamins qui ce qui ce marquis on
savent souvent plus que la l'enseignant
qui est bon ce sujet donc voila moi je
leur jette pas du tout la pierre c'est
très très bien justement il faut donner
des moyens aux associations qui sont un
peu extérieurs aux établissements
scolaires d'intervenir alors y en a on y
arrive mais c'est très compliqué c'est
très compliqué et puis et bien voilà on
n'est pas assez nombreux parce qu'il ya
pas assez de moyens et votre association
a mis aussi en place quelques outils
très pratiques pour accompagner au mieux
je crois
qu'on a mis surtout en place
au delà de l'accueil des départs aux
dons qu'on a on a des vivres est destiné
aux parents pour vraiment leur donner
mode d'emploi mais vis-à-vis des jeunes
c'est déjà dans tous les endroits où on
peut les distribuer le michto med pour
leur expliquer à partir de quel moment
la relation amoureuse
risque de virer vers des situations qui
sont qui sont de la prostitution s'il
faut appeler les choses par leur nom
donc on est là pour leur dire soyez
vigilant jusque-là ces feux verts là il
ya des risques et à partir de là c'est
c'est de la prostitution bon donc ces
petits outils là évidemment
dans les écoles dans les collèges
ouais plutôt dans les tous les
formations qu'on fait pour donner ça aux
autres travailleurs sociaux éducateurs
etc pour leur dire utiliser ça pour
aborder le sujet et le faire de façon
soft et sans braquer les gamines pis on
demande aussi les professionnels sont là
pour le coup c'est pour ça que je vous
dis 14 millions c'est très bien mais
quand on voit la demande des
professionnels
que ce soit la pjj et gendarmes les
policiers les traverser tout le monde
aujourd'hui demandent à être formés et
je le répète je croyais que c'était la
mauvaise volonté aujourd'hui je sais que
voilà il n'y a pas les moyens nous on
fait ce qu'on peut et des tout petits
moyens qu'on peut avoir on en espère
plus haut
si on n'a pas une bonne nouvelle mais il
ya un lien chantiers considérables à
mener auprès de tous ces gens qui au
contact des gamines dit non c'est pas
comment traiter le problème donc on nous
on utilise le théâtre pour mettre en
place des situations qu'on fait après
rejouer par les travailleurs sociaux
pour l'inter un but et vous à la place
de la gamine vous allez comprendre
pourquoi elle réagit comme ça et à du
théâtre on a aussi dans nos modules tout
l'aspect existeront internet et pour
leur expliquer effectivement comment ça
se passe pour qu'ils aient les moyens
nous on a aussi beaucoup l'aspect
juridique qui connaissent très très bas
parce que la majorité sexuelle à 15 ans
ça n'existe pas sur le plan légal ça
n'existe pas et au monde herbe à 8 15
ans la majorité sexuelle ce qu'on entend
tout le temps auprès des jeunes et des
gens qui seraient censés accueillir les
parents et les jeunes voient là et qui
nous parle de majorité sexuelle dont il
ya plein de boulot à faire pour juste
donner des clés pour essayer de faire en
sorte que nous on essaye d'éviter que
les gamineries delà et quand elle arrive
là essayez quand même de les envoyer
auprès des bonnes personnes dont nous on
a ouvert les ados sexo c'est des lieux
où on essaye effectivement d'accueillir
d'accueillir les gamines de leur
entourage et essayer de travailler avec
elle sur
cette espèce de de glissement vers une
vie qui va être qui va être sabotée et
le rôle des associations est donc
primordial pour lutter contre contre ce
fléau je rappelle le nom de la vôtre ac
peut agir contre la prostitution des
enfants merci beaucoup armel le big mac
os d'avoir passé ce moment avec nous
merci à vous nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez retrouver ce numéro de la grande
interview sur notre site internet rt
france point tv à bientôt
[Musique]